una catástrofe que aumenta a medida que
pasan las horas cientos de personas
murieron y miles más resultaron heridas
tras el potente terremoto de magnitud
6,1 en la provincia oriental paktika en
afganistán que se sintió también en los
vecinos pakistán e india los
supervivientes están conmocionados
en mi familia han muerto siete miembros
en una habitación cinco en otro cuatro
en otra tres en otra ya no puedo hablar
mi corazón está destrozado
prepara el ataque
cuando el techo se me vino encima pensé
que me habían disparado con una pistola
me dolía y me ardía el cuerpo intenté
levantarme pero no pude
naciones unidas- señaló que la falta de
maquinaria está dificultando las tareas
de búsqueda y rescate de los
supervivientes entre los escombros el
organismo está intentando enviar ayuda a
través de la embajada de turquía en la
nación asiática mientras que la unión
europea solicitó aportar asistencia
internacional en un gesto inusual los
talibanes permitieron el acceso a las
organizaciones humanitarias en el
terreno
si probablemente al menos 15 millones de
dólares inmediatamente para responder a
las necesidades multisectoriales nos
preocupan no sólo los artículos no
alimentarios y llevar a la gente a los
refugios y proporcionar suministros
médicos sino también prevenir las
enfermedades transmitidas por el agua
se trata del seísmo más mortífero en dos
décadas y añade presión a un país sumido
en una profunda crisis económica y
social desde la toma de poder por el
grupo talibán hace un año y el bloqueo
de los fondos extranjeros pese a que el
60% de la población afgana depende de
esa ayuda para sobrevivir